Speaker 1: Hey, this is a truly bizarre story.
Remember this guy, Milo Yiannopoulos? Milo
Yiannopoulos was this gay British provocateur
who got very involved in American politics. He
was a darling of the right, and he would say
horrible things. And then he had a sort of
it was it's not so much a falling out. He had,
I guess we'd call it a PR problem because he
was in a interviewed in a show. And I want
to be careful with the language I use here
where he sort of said it's kind of okay when there
are relationships between a he he wasn't saying
pre-pubescent kids, but he was, I believe, talking
about like sort of like 12 and 13 year olds
and adult men. It was very, very strange.
And he quickly was dropped by the right
wing establishment. They no longer he was no
longer useful to them. And he's made a couple
of attempts at comebacks. One of the things he
did is he became heterosexual. Now, I know that
when I say that, you might be wondering, well,
did he really become heterosexual? Was he never
actually gay, is what? I don't know. I'm just
telling you. He says he is now heterosexual
and I don't even have an interest in commenting on
whether that's a real thing. But he he claims that
he is now heterosexual and this has allowed him,
to some degree to at least attempt to enter the
mainstream American political milieu. He now
reportedly is Marjorie Taylor, Greens unpaid
intern. This is just bizarre. It's wacky. The
Washington Post reporting Milo Yiannopoulos,
far right provocateur, is a marjorie Taylor GREENE
intern. Former Breitbart editor is summer intern
for Marjorie Taylor GREENE. He announced that
he had finally been persuaded out of retirement,
saying he was hired for an
unpaid internship with a friend.
He attached a photo of a congressional intern ID
badge on top of a Louis Vuitton bag showing he's
an intern in Marjorie Taylor Greene's office. He
her office didn't explain what his duties are,
but she said so I have an intern that was
raped by a priest as a young teen, was gay,
has offended everyone at some point, turned his
life back to Jesus in church and changed his life.
Great story. Great story. The statement was sent
after the Washington Post article published.
It also suggested the media should interview a
colleague of hers about her trans daughter. Green
named the colleague using transphobic language.
So it's a completely bizarre story. But it's not
only that Milo appears to be an unpaid intern of
Marjorie Taylor GREENE. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
also now has a very strange podcast, and he's off
camera, but he sort of seems to be like a sidekick
here. This is one of the strangest stories I've
seen. Here is just 30 seconds of Marjorie Taylor
Green's recent podcast episode. I believe this
is from yesterday. And you hear Milo off camera,
sort of her her sidekick, I guess. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Tell us more. Give us give us
a give it. Tell us about California.
Speaker 3: Well, California has advanced
a bill to become a transgender sanctuary.
It was introduced by Democrat Senator Scott
Wiener. Why are they always called Wiener?
Speaker 4: Why are they always called Wiener?
Speaker 6: Anthony Weiner. Scott
Wiener. Now did all the wiener.
I don't think they all got together.
Speaker 1: Now that Milo is heterosexual,
he can do that type of thing. I guess
this is a new form of comedy for Milo.
Now that he's newly heterosexual.
Speaker 4: Some of them are
wanting to get rid of the wieners.
Speaker 6: I mean, this is like.
Like the whole weenie chop thing. Can you
imagine being a mother wanting to do that to your
child? I can't comprehend it. I'm sorry
I'm making jokes, but it's not funny.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, transphobia actually
isn't new to Milo. And there is a contingent.
There's a transphobic contingent of the gay
community. This is just a thing that exists. It's
not. I'm not personally attacking anyone. There
is. You might have heard of trans exclusionary,
radical feminism called Terf trf. There's
also a contingent of the gay community that
is not big on that. That's not big on trans
that when Milo was gay. And again, I'm using
the language that he uses. When Milo used to be
gay, he also was was transphobic. And in fact,
when I interviewed Milo years ago on the show,
one of the things, if I recall correctly, that we
talked about and I don't know who brought it up,
were his views on feminism. I'm sorry? We know his
views on feminism, what his views on trans vote
on transgender. And it exposed his transphobia.
So just all very strange. And I don't know what
the next step is like. What is what's interning
for Marjorie Taylor GREENE? Where is that a
jumping off point to? And I guess we can only
wait and see if it's just a summer internship.
By the way, Milo's. I think he's almost 40.
I don't know. You know, it's all very strange, but
there it is. You now know everything that I know